imaginez un soldat la taille d'un
insecte larmes secret absolu
si vous donnez tout le monde de super
pouvoirs ce sera le chaos
on peut faire pour l'arrêter je connais
quelques uns
je t'observe depuis un moment
tu es différent
et je crois que chacun de nous a droit
la rédemption tu es d'accord
absolument s'introduire chez les gens
pour leur voler des trucs tu l'as effet
c'est terminé
qu'est ce que vous attendez moi devrait
être introduite chez quelqu'un pour lui
voler un truc
évidemment est ce que tu es
et à devenir un héros bien le post
humain pouvoir
il faut que vous appreniez à le
maîtriser
et voilà vos meilleurs alliés des
mignonnes
de cette taille vous avez une force
surhumaine
vous êtes comme une balle
il faut que vous appreniez attraper vous
allez apprendre à les hits monfreid moi
comment c'est comme ça qu'on frappe
vous avez voulu garder le costume pour
vous
maintenant ça va se retourner contre
vous et détruire tout ce que vous avez
de plus cher
tu croyais pouvoir empêcher l'avenir
tu n'es qu'un polaire
je suis entré je sais oui c'est pas moi
qui ai eu l'idée